[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
politique à table sur LCP l'émission où
on parle agriculture alimentation
écologique et aussi politique et cette
semaine nous recevons Claude Bluzet il
est majordome de Matignon depuis 1988 il
vient de partir à la retraite et c'est
lui qui va passer sur le grill
aujourd'hui avec moi pour vous cuisiner
Claude Buzet et bien Jean-Pierre
montagne bonjour Jean-Pierre bonjour
Brigitte et bonjour Claude Buzet bonjour
bonjour Claude Bizet vous êtes donc
l'homme de confiance de 14 premiers
ministres de la Cinquième République
tout jeune retraitée vous venez de
quitter Matignon après avoir servi
pendant 33 années en tant que premier
maître d'hôtel est responsable de cave
vous avez débuté à 29 ans auprès de
Michel Rocard sans arrêt jusqu'à Jean
Castex qui vous a remis la Légion
d'honneur il y a quelques semaines vous
avez donc aussi côtoyé Edith Cresson
Édouard Balladur Alain Juppé Lionel
Jospin Jean-Pierre Raffarin Dominique de
Villepin François Fillon Jean-Marc
Ayraud Manuel Valls Bernard Cazeneuve et
Édouard Philippe vous avez aussi
accueilli les plus grandes ce monde qui
singer Aya sarafat en passant par la
reine d'Angleterre mais vous avez
toujours gardé les pieds sur terre et la
tête froide en allant vous ressourcer
chez vous à Baume-les-Dames la
Franche-Comté le Doubs qui a inspiré le
menu du jour Jean-Pierre oui avec un
poulet aux champignons mais pas
n'importe quel un des morilles et en
dessert une tarte normande aux pommes
bien sûr dans le dessous des plats quel
est le rôle de maître d'hôtel à Matignon
vous nous livrerez tous les secrets du
protocole des dîners d'État mais aussi
les confidences sur les habitudes
alimentaires de nos anciens premiers
ministres dans les pieds dans le plat
gros plan sur l'incroyable démarche
inclusive d'un restaurant Le Reflet qui
emploie des serveurs et quelques
cuisiniers atteints de trisomie 21
allez on passe à table tout de suite
cuisine et confidence
[Musique]
Claude buzel j'ai lu que vous auriez dit
et je note la métaphore culinaire bien
joué certains premiers ministres
prennent le melon mais ce n'est pas une
généralité et bien moi je dis alors que
je vous connais à peine depuis 10
minutes vous n'avez pas le melon le
Boulard comme on dit et ce qui me fait
dire ça c'est le menu que vous avez
choisi et oui lorsqu'on a côtoyé comme
majordome 14 premiers ministres comme
viennent de dire Brigitte organiser des
milliers de banquets avec du lourd au
menu un foie gras langoustine sol lot
médaillon de bœuf etc on s'est dit avec
Brigitte que vous alliez vous l'homme de
Matignon challengeait l'Assemblée
nationale et exiger ici le grand jeu le
syndrome de la grosse tête quoi et bien
non calme des stick à l'humilité vous
n'avez pas essayé de nous épater avec du
chauffe et des plats bling bling non
vous avez choisi une recette culte de
votre terroir et encore je sens bien que
votre sens de l'État et des finances
publiques vous a conduit à exiger ni un
poulet de Bresse ni le vin jaune qui
aurait alourdi la facture de ce poulet
aux morilles que vous nous proposez de
alors pourquoi ce plat particulièrement
alors déjà bon bien sûr merci de
m'accueillir dans votre émission déjà on
va remettre les choses
en place tout de suite je n'ai jamais
dit que les premiers savaient chopé le
melon c'était repris par des
journalistes jamais je me serais permis
de dire une chose pareille il y a
beaucoup de respect pour tous les gens
que j'ai eu l'honneur de servir pendant
pendant ces 30 quand vous commencez par
dire que les journalistes disent
n'importe quoi alors parfois souvent
c'est vrai ça non en tout cas j'ai
jamais dit ça vraiment quand j'ai lu ça
j'ai surpris d'avoir lu ça sur sur
internet
je me permettrai de dire ça je dis je
vais rendre du respect pour tous les
gens que j'ai eu l'honneur de servir et
vous nous en parlerez juste après
racontez-nous l'histoire de ce plat
pourquoi avoir demandé un poulet aux
morilles alors l'histoire j'ai commencé
à travailler dans un restaurant à
Baume-les-Dames à côté de Besançon qui
était toi et Michelin et un des plats
signatures c'était le poulet aux
morilles au vin jaune et j'ai servi ça
pendant des quelques mois dans
l'apprentissage commençait à ces mots
frère qui était cuisiné également dans
un restaurant bien souvent ce plat
également voilà et j'ai tout retrouvé ce
plat délicieux et élabori c'est quand
même un champignon qu'on trouve beaucoup
en Franche-Comté donc voilà ça vient à
la maison
je cuisine quotidiennement pour mon
épouse et moi mais bon c'est pas la
grande cuisine c'est cuisine comment on
fait pour sa maison quoi
j'achète tout fait le poulet rôti le
poulet du dimanche autrement c'est une
volaille poché évidemment pour avec une
sauce au riz
mais je fais pas souvent ce plat là
quand même c'est vraiment il faut
vraiment du temps et je vais en avoir
bientôt mais pas encore assez et vous
disiez des morilles on les trouvait
beaucoup dans votre région aux Ali les
ramasser
et on dit pas souvent on va au Moril
c'est compliqué donc quand on en trouve
on en parle pas donc on les garde ceux
qui en ont trouvé les gardes pour eux et
ils disent pas les endroits où on les
trouve donc non non alors on va le
goûter l'eau oui on va le goûter bien
sûr et pendant ce temps
-là as
tuces paraît un très bon poulet aux
morilles parce que vous vous savez nous
raconter les histoires alors on peut
utiliser des morilles fraîches mais
aussi des morilles séchées et faites-les
tremper c'est une astuce dans du lait
tiède plutôt que de l'eau
vous obtiendrez ainsi une infusion qui
pourra ensuite vous servir comme base de
sauce pour la préparation de votre plat
et ensuite on peut rajouter
effectivement du vin jaune si vous ne
trouvez pas de morilles ou si vous les
trouvez trop cher en ces périodes ou le
pouvoir d'achat appelle sur le panier de
l'aménagère et bien quel champignon pour
les remplacer bien on peut faire ça avec
des champignons de Paris des
chanterelles ou des bolets qui font la
faire même si au final ça n'a pas tout à
fait le même goût alors quels légumes
pour accompagner ce poulet aux morilles
parce que vous avez bien vu les porris
les morilles d'abord les morilles c'est
un peu toxique donc il faut pas en
mettre trop avec le poulet regardez là
on en a que quelques-unes il s'agit pas
de remplir l'assiette de morilles on
peut se retrouver à l'infirmerie alors
là on a des épinards c'est une bonne
idée parce que c'est digeste on peut
aussi mettre des pâtes fraîches ou des
pommes de terre vapeur pour rissolées
qu'est-ce que vous en dites comme vous
moi mon servez ça de mémoire c'était du
riz conservé avec ça oui tout simplement
du riz neutre
et le chef de ce restaurant qui
s'appelait Henri Aubret qui est décédé
il était très généreux avec les morilles
parce que franchement il y en avait il y
en avait énormément c'était plutôt des
morilles avec du poulet et c'était
vraiment il en reste toujours dans les
plat et on faisait plaisir avec mes
collègues de manger ce qui restait dans
les plats parce qu'on adore ça donc les
Marius je connais bien quand même mais
chez vous le plat c'est pas le poulet à
la Franc-Comtoise non c'est pas ça le
plat typique avec du comté non
ça me dit pas trop plutôt nous c'est la
saucisse de Morteau avec de la
cancoillotte des pommes sautées de la
salade verte ça c'est le truc qu'on aime
bien alors on a vu que vous étiez
Chauvin en matière de cuisine mais
est-ce que vous de temps en temps vous
sortir de vous sortez de votre frontière
de votre terroir et vous avez parce que
vous avez on le verra plus tard vous
avez côtoyé plein de chef d'État
étrangers si vous avez un peu l'esprit
exotique de tantôt alors oui j'aimerais
cuisine coréenne moi à coréenne la
colline coréenne exactement un barbecue
coréen la cuisine italienne également
qui est absolument géniale
et puis j'ai découvert comment la
cuisine coréenne
dans les déplacements à l'étranger
pendant
33 ans 33 ans à peu près je suis allé
pratiquement partout avec eux les
accompagner organiser des réceptions
donc on avait l'occasion de
cuisine
du monde c'est pareil
aussi on vous a servi du vin jaune avec
ce plat puisque on en trouve aussi dans
dans le plat cuisiné par chez Françoise
alors le 20 jaune c'est un vin de la
région d'Arbois avec une appellation
Arbois protégée le cépage c'est du
savagnin vous confirmez et l'élevage il
se fait en fût de chêne pendant 6 ans et
trois mois c'est très très long et ça
lui donne une belle couleur mort dorée à
l'arrivée c'est un bon choix ou pas
c'est un bon choix en prenant soin
surtout de jamais remplir le fût de vin
de façon à ce qu'un voile se dépose pour
le vin qui va donner ce goût de de noix
fraîche etc c'est curieux comme vin
c'est typique 120 qui il semblerait que
sur le vin qui se garde le plus au monde
s'évapore en général on remplit les
lacunes
avec une autre bouteille qu'on reprend
là je sais pas je pense pas qu'on le
refait hein
spécialiste du vin là non mais la corde
met là mets 20 c'est très intéressant
donc il y a effectivement un peu de vin
jaune dans la sauce qui a été cuit donc
ça lui donne est-ce que c'est
intelligent on m'a on remet du vin jaune
à table avec ce plat c'est ça c'est
d'accord oui je pense qu'on peut
remettre du vin jaune avatar pour
renforcer justement le goût du plat ça
lui donne une texture particulière aussi
un non ça renforce un peu le les arômes
parce que les
gens ne s'y retrouveront pas dans ce vin
c'est particulier quand même
particulier
mais encore un petit peu ou alors avec
du vieux comté ça va parfaitement avec
pas mal ça mais sinon boire du vin jaune
comme ça je vais faire de la peine à mes
amis jurassien mais c'est pas facile on
a des vins beaucoup plus facile
d'approche comme les sauvaniens les
codes du général
grande gare mais ouais on va revenir à
l'alimentation et on va voir si vous
êtes vraiment incollables c'est le quiz
alors vous avez reçu à Matignon la reine
d'Angleterre qui vient de disparaître à
l'âge de 96 ans vous connaissiez donc
ces goûts culinaires lors d'un dîner
officiel au Louvre préparé par le chef
Camaro un plat paraît-il la fille
sursauter seriez-vous nous dire lequel
attendez
alors la langoustine qui pleure le
hérisson Oni la mésange en cocotte ou le
pied de cochon en aumônière sachant les
goûts culinaires de la reine quel plat
aurait pu la faire sursauter
peut-être le hérisson non bah oui
exactement j'étais sûr le hérisson
et
cotonie il est fait d'une brioche lardée
de lamelles d'amande et dont le cœur a
été enlevé après cuisson et
effectivement je crois qu'elle est très
amatrice de foie gras en revanche mais
là elle est un peu sursauter à cause du
nom
véritablement alors au rayon des
spécialités culinaires du Doubs votre
région il y a le sirop de sapin alors
êtes-vous incollable sur cette
gourmandise les affirmations suivantes
sont-elles vraies ou fausses dites-nous
ah il est confectionné à partir
d'aiguilles de sapin qui sont fermentés
dans du sucre vrai ou faux
j'ai envie de dire oui alors c'est faux
et pas des aiguilles
de sapin de type Norman peuvent
provoquer des vomissements vrai ou faux
je crois que oui parce que je crois que
c'est je crois que c'est vrai vrai
exactement ça de Noël d'ailleurs c'est
beaucoup de normal et fais attention de
pas les pas trop toucher c'est
exactement
il calme les douleurs d'arthrose vrai ou
faux
j'espère c'est vrai
et puis la chef pâtissière jessicapri
alpato a conçu des yaourts fraises sapin
vrai ou faux
ça doit être vrai alors c'est vrai
exactement
est-ce que vous êtes très attentif à la
saisonnalité des produits à ce que vous
achetez en fonction de la période alors
pour la maison Matignon pour moi
personnellement vous personnellement
alors oui plutôt oui
vous êtes vraiment attention il fallait
pas sortir des fraises en plein hiver
quoi ça ça faisait pas non non on fait
attention à ça d'abord le coup les goûts
le goût n'est pas des Lego bien
différents c'est des fruits qui sont pas
toujours bien donc vous avez passé 34
ans à Matignon il y a 34 ans déjà vous
êtes attention aux fraises l'hiver il y
en avait pas de changer
pour mettre des choses comme ça
voilà se faire défoncer après parce
qu'on a servi des fruits voilà
évolué que l'alimentation a beaucoup
évolué au fil du temps là-bas non
alors si on parle des menus de
l'alimentation générale des menus en
général oui écoutez il y a 30 ans en
arrière c'était c'était vraiment des
repas qui était qui était incroyables il
y avait des apéritifs avec des
amuse-bouches avec une entrée un plat un
dessert un fromage pardon fromage
dessert dietive vin blanc vin rouge etc
c'était bien ça c'était au début on
arrive à Matignon il y a quelques
dizaines d'années et au fil du temps
quand même ça la sobriété est passée par
là c'est passé par là et on a vraiment
réduit tout ça jusqu'à arriver autant de
l'époque de hors Balladur où il avait
fait supprimer les entrées carrément
mais il vient repasser le plat ce qui
était pas le mauvais idée d'ailleurs et
alors pourquoi parce qu'il aimait pas
personnellement les entrées ou parce
qu'il fallait aller plus vite ça va rien
d'avoir une entrée et penser que c'était
bien on repasse sur le point une autre
fois et d'ailleurs un ministre je me
souviens Charles pas dit toujours mais
il doit il y a rien à bouffer quand on
vient Matignon et dor Balladur il disait
mais Charles vous avez du pain et du
beurre à satiété et on repasse le plat
Didier tout à l'heure Brigitte que vous
cuisiniez parce que vous êtes un
cuisinier dans l'âme est-ce que vous
avez chez vous vous avez des petits
trucs qui vous sont arrivés de ces 34
ans de Matignon ça vous a servi pour je
regarde un peu des petits trucs de
cuisine ouais bien sûr
que je fais donc vous avez vous avez pas
essayé de faire un peu de temps en temps
de cuisine un peu plus élaborée j'ai
peur de pas réussir et puis il y a des
recettes que vous ne connaissiez pas que
vous avez appris justement là-bas vous
avez peut-être essayé de refaire chez
vous
des choses même simples ils mettent
beaucoup de temps à préparer ce qu'ils
font et vraiment j'ai pas envie de
passer trois heures à la cuisine pour
être
ça vous plaît mais pas tant que ça
finalement
j'aime bien j'apprécie je ferai de la
peine je me dis moi j'adore la
nourriture comment les enfants sorti des
notaires des pâtes et des choses comme
ça moi c'est mon truc
régressif
le repas occupe une large place et
particulièrement à Matignon alors c'est
souvent là que ça raconte les meilleures
histoires c'est la brève de comptoir
alors on vous a demandé de réfléchir
Claude Buzet a une un souvenir autour
d'un repas à Matignon est-ce qu'il y en
a un qui vous est revenu à l'esprit
alors oui je venais d'arriver à Mathéo
depuis à peu près 15 jours c'était en
1988 je suis arrivé en octobre fin que
88 et je servais un dîner avec Michel
Rocard le premier Ste belge le premier
Espagnol
et le président de la Commission
européenne j'étais 4 à dîner donc là ça
a mangé du pré Istre et
au bout d'un moment je rentre dans la
salle et je vois Michel Rocard debout
sur une chaise en train de donner des
coups de serviettes dans lustres il y
avait une ampoule qui est en train de
brûler et sa fumait et alors c'était je
lui dis mais c'est quoi ce truc je viens
d'arriver en plus hein
je sais pas quoi et ça m'a vraiment
surpris mais ça c'est drôle je vous ai
dit que le système électrique a été un
petit problème ici mais surtout quand on
arrive dans ces maisons là en plus avec
trois premiers c'est un président
Commission européenne c'était pas rien
je vais arriver moi je sortais de chez
un amiral c'était pas le même travail
quand même donc voilà parce que vous
étiez dans la marine avant j'étais au
service du chef d'état-major de la
marine place de la Concorde à l'époque
c'est encore là et donc c'était un
couple et c'est tout donc j'avais ces
deux personnes à servir voilà donc là
j'arrive et je vois des choses assez
incroyables dans ces maisons là quand on
arrive c'est surprenant une maison
Matignon ça vous a surpris de voir un
premier ministre
cette impressionné parce que c'est la
première de dans cet état-là
est-ce que ça représente bien Michel
Rocard est-ce que c'était quelqu'un de
plus simple dans la vie c'est quelqu'un
très très agréable quelqu'un de très
sympathique également moi je dis j'ai
vraiment commencé avec lui donc j'ai
commencé à l'accompagner à l'étranger
etc on se connaissait bien on s'est vu
souvent c'est quelqu'un de remarquable
alors vous avez donc servi à Matignon
depuis 1988 donc sous Michel Rocard vous
connaissez toutes les habitudes et les
secrets de nos premiers ministres c'est
le dessous des plats
revenons d'abord sur votre parcours
Claude bluet il est d'une longévité
exceptionnelle puisque vous avez servi
pendant près de 34 ans à l'hôtel de
Matignon la résidence du Premier
ministre premier maître d'hôtel et chef
de cave vous êtes le garant du protocole
vous avez connu tous les chefs de
gouvernement de Michel Rocard à Jean
Castex mais aussi les plus grandes ce
monde retour sur une carrière au service
de l'État avec Hélène Bonduelle au
premier étage de Matignon le bureau du
protocole c'est là que Claude Bluzet a
passé 34 ans de sa vie
quelques photos que j'ai laissé encore
mais je vais emmené tout à l'heure il y
a quelques heures de sa retraite le
premier maître d'hôtel de Matignon est
un peu nostalgique alors là c'était avec
le départ d'Édouard Philippe Emmanuel
Valls Bernard Cazeneuve mais j'ai gardé
tout ça c'est un beau souvenir puis bon
je vais regarder évidemment on part pas
comme ça Matignon comme ça quoi là
Claude Buzet a servi 14 premiers
ministres un record de longévité alors
les salons de Matignon n'ont plus aucun
secret pour lui on arrive dans le salon
jaune où il y aura un déjeuner
aujourd'hui les vins ils sont à l'envers
tu modifies
organiser les dîners privés comme les
repas officiels il a supervisé les plus
grandes cérémonies
c'était quelque chose d'assez important
on avait la garde à cheval dans le parc
c'était magnifique
et on l'a servi dans ses salons on a
servi également les didiques et passer
en salon là également sur un déjeuner
qui était assis ici d'ailleurs c'était
très sympa mais derrière le face la
règle du maître d'hôtel c'est discrétion
et adaptation chaque premier ministre a
ses exigences son régime alimentaire
Claude Buzet lui assez technique pour ne
pas commettre d'un père la vie du prince
au niveau de la cuisine nous appartient
quasiment on essaie d'avoir des
informations un petit peu avant on a
toujours quelqu'un qui l'a connu quelque
part bonjour messieurs dames et
l'endroit stratégique c'est ici ça va et
c'est d'ici tous les repas qu'on s'est
ramatinum il se compris pour le premier
soyez donc ça c'est les assiettes qui
vont servir plutôt prévu et ça plutôt
personnel on fait une différence un peu
d'assiette quand même c'est pas le même
prix
200 plateaux repas préparés chaque jour
un service de 6 heures à une heure du
matin et ici au cycle Buzet est un peu
le maître des lieux
[Musique]
les chefs qui décidons du service c'est
eux qui décident de quand il se doit
partir et comment ça doit partir prendre
on donne le tempo les dernières
consignes qu'on a du préavis à l'instant
même voilà à l'instant on dit voilà il
veut manger il y a toujours une un qui
n'aime pas le poisson qui n'aiment pas
la viande etc et les cuisines sont très
réactifs
et tous ne sont pas de fin gourmet Edith
Cresson par exemple avait un peu
révolutionné les cuisines de Matignon
pas de pâtisserie beaucoup de poissons
et arrow sur les sauces
donc c'est une personne qui semble faire
attention à ce qu'elle veut manger donc
on doit éviter les sauces éviter le
beurre et faire plutôt des choses
du genre des légumes madame la Première
ministre n'est pas grande amatrice de
vin pas de chance pour Claude Buzet qui
à l'époque est aussi en charge de la
cave elle
peut très très peu un tout petit peu de
vin que le fromage mais vraiment pas
grand chose
mais de faire boire beaucoup
elle boit très peu les gens qui
l'entourent boivent pas davantage
non c'est préférable pour travailler
quand même 30 ans plus tard à l'heure de
quitter les lieux le maître d'hôtel
chevronné est fier d'être resté en
contact avec bon nombre d'anciens
locataires de matinée
[Musique]
33 ans donc Claude brizet au service de
Matignon c'est quoi votre secret de
longévité
écoutez je sais pas moi je pense que je
me suis bien entendu avec tous les
premiers ministres j'ai fait mon travail
comme mes collègues d'ailleurs
on est un certain nombre les plus jeunes
ont la moitié de mon âge mais ça fait 10
ans qu'ils sont là ils font ça très bien
et je pense qu'ils dureront longtemps
aussi également c'est quoi les qualités
indispensables pour être un bon maître
d'hôtel
alors déjà Mathieu faut être disponible
quand même c'est une grande
disponibilité c'est un sacerdoce
quasiment attignon on y passe sa vie
j'ai passé la moitié de ma vie quand
même dans cette maison là et puis
surtout faire son travail comme dirait
d'orphelie sérieusement sur ce point
d'eau au sérieux je pense c'est un peu
la règle du jeu pour tenir dans ses
maisons surtout la discrétion de tout et
n'importe quoi vous devez être toujours
être disponible vous devez toujours
rendre service même si parfois ce sont
des caprices
alors non du Caprices non les caprices
non par contre je pense qu'on doit pas
dire non quand le président de quelque
chose il a un travail à faire il a une
grosse charge de travail et s'il a
besoin de quelque chose on va pas lui
dire non on peut pas faire toujours oui
yes
en tout cas c'est non on peut toujours
possible on peut faire on a une maison
on est équipé pour on a essayé une
grande maison il y a du monde on est là
pour ça et moi je me je me refuse
d'entendre dire non ou en tout cas j'ai
jamais fait j'imagine que tout est très
millimétré très organisé il y a quand
même beaucoup d'imprévus dans votre
métier il peut y avoir un déjeuner 12h30
le prix sous appel en disant va être 10
ou 12 à déjeuner donc il faut il faut
vraiment être prêt ah oui comme ça
c'est arrivé des fois c'est arrivé c'est
arrivé parfois souvent même d'ailleurs
ça arrive mais bon au dernier moment il
se passe quelque chose il réunissent ses
collaborateurs mais je dis la cuisine
faites ça si on a rien c'est une
omelette avec des pommes de terre ça va
pas aller loin
on fait attention on a des produits
frais donc on commande on évite d'avoir
des trucs mais au débotté vous pouvez
pas faire un repas pour 20 personnes si
on peut faire
des tomates
mais il y a jamais de problème avec ça
on a fait souvent avec Édouard Philippe
par exemple alors 14 premiers ministres
questions quel est le premier ministre
avec avec qui vous avez le plus de
complicité vous parlez tout à l'heure de
Michel Rocard parce que c'était le
premier mais quel avec qui vous êtes
sentie le plus proche le plus ça c'est
vraiment la question que j'ai à tous les
coups merci
et je peux pas répondre à cette question
ils sont tous différents vous n'avez pas
envie de faire le je ne veux pas
[Musique]
[Rires]
le régisseur de cette résidence qui qui
est à sosie
à fabriquer lui-même à barbecue avec une
grande bouteille de gaz qui la coupe en
deux dans le sens à longueur il a collé
4 depuis 4 roulettes et Edouard Philippe
c'est un plaisir à faire des barbecues
là-dessus donc par contre il sait le
faire mais comme personne ça ne part
jamais
toujours aimé il a une façon de mettre
le bois le papier etc il est incroyable
mais sinon vous me disiez que c'était
quelqu'un qui mangeait très simplement à
Matignon
c'est souvent des pâtes il adore les
pâtes et c'est souvent quand il faisait
beau c'est un sandwich dans le parc
il prenait un sandwich il allait manger
sur les marches du pavillon au fond du
jardin
ou alors ils sortent dehors manger une
pizza comme ça
c'était sa nourriture
dans le reportage Brésil d'ailleurs je
l'ai vu sur sauter il y a une image
forte c'est quand
voit cette sorcière est agacée et vous
avez dit ça lui ressemble ça veut dire
quoi elle était comme ça un peu un peu
dur
c'est pas c'était pas la peine
de Claude Buzet c'est d'avoir proposé
une sorcière j'aurais pas dû que j'ai
faite
aux choses à faire elle était sur un
déjeuner important par mois on a eu
rarement des déjeuner donc avec Madame
cresson donc c'était exceptionnel puis
peut-être qu'elle mais c'est vrai
qu'elle fait ou non
petit comité voilà et ce jour-là il y
avait ce déjeuné mais c'est vrai qu'elle
prend pas elle faisait attention à ce
qu'elle mangeait quand même elle était
très donc pour écouter la cuisine
visible
je me rappelais plus effectivement il y
avait une liste de consignes mais bon
c'était comme ça je veux dire son
offusque pas pour autant quand ils sont
dans leur truc ils disent pas merci tout
ça c'est pas grave ils sont
reconnaissant plus tard ouais bien sûr
non non bien sûr brigitte a dit que vous
aviez rencontré dans son dans ton dans
votre préambule il y a assez rarafat
est-ce que quand il y avait des
personnalités comme ça qui était parfois
un peu paranoïaques parce qu'elles
étaient menacées et c'était compliqué
avec les services secrets ce qu'ils
inspectaient les plats avant est-ce que
vous étiez obligés de dîner des plats
préparés ce qu'il y avait une espèce de
parano autour de ce que l'on pouvait
manger quand on sait qu'on peut se faire
empoisonner en mangeant ça n'a pas été
le cas à ma connaissance pour réussir à
faire on a fait plein
on a eu des virus qui mettaient
quelqu'un en cuisine pour voir un peu ce
qu'on faisait si on l'a vu mais c'est
rarement c'était rarement fait quand
même mais cela dit on a tout d'abord
toutes les consignes du protocole du
ministère des Affaires étrangères il
donne toutes les informations sur ce
qu'il faut faire et pas faire chose à
offrir ou pas offrir etc
déjà pour une visite une visite une
visite d'État donc c'est le plus haut
niveau dans les visites en France alors
là c'est là où on a la garde à cheval
dans le parc de Matignon pour accueillir
les personnalités etc et le Quai d'Orsay
nous envoie toutes les informations
quand même en fonction de ce que le
poste du pays nous a communiqué donc on
sait exactement ce qu'ils aiment ce
qu'ils n'aiment pas tout est bien fait
on fait il y a pas d'imperts de fait on
a trop on est trop beaucoup trop
attentif à tout ça pour faire une
boulette je peux dire vous disiez Edith
Cresson elle préférait déjeuner en
petits comité il y a des premiers
ministres qui qui déjeunent en famille
qui prennent leur repas parfois avec
leurs femmes leurs enfants le midi
jamais non le midi c'est déjeuné de
travail c'est collaborateurs ou
rapidement un plateau de leur bureau
parce qu'ils ont pas beaucoup de temps
ça sandwich ils doivent partir dans la
voiture ils mangera sandwich avec une
bouteille d'eau puis voilà vous voyez
c'est souvent ça et la femme du Premier
ministre elle peut aller en cuisine se
préparer quelque chose si elle est dans
les appartements privés alors la fin du
préhistoire a une cuisine dans
l'appartement
mais une cuisine une cuisine aveugle
donc pour cuisiner dans une pièce où il
y a pas de fenêtre c'est c'est pas
terrible madame
pour l'aération c'est pas terrible ah
ouais
quand même non non
elle était là avec moi
ou des trucs qualifiés mais bien ouais
autrement jamais et par contre le soir
même le soir le premier
rarement que sa famille sauf le weekend
évidemment où il est un peu libre là
sinon il travaille tous les soirs il y
avait des réunions des des travailleurs
tous les jours quasiment alors vous avez
approché la reine d'Angleterre qui a
disparu à quelque chose absolument alors
est-ce que c'était une fille une
fourchette c'était où elle était elle
allait manger pas beaucoup vous savez
donc
c'est dîner de ces dîner officiel
c'est pas le bon moment pour être à
table je veux dire ça
non parce que même si vous avez des
super menus il y a timing qui est très
précis il faut que ça aille très vite si
pour un peu ça traîne un peu quelqu'un
on est obligé de débarrasser même s'ils
ont pas fini vous voyez des serviettes
etc
plus que 5 minutes tu en es où est-ce
que le café est servi etc donc vraiment
il fallait faire une donc je pense pas
que c'est là où on a pris le plus les
repas on apprécié pardon le plus ça
c'est pas frustrant pour les chefs
cuisiniers qui se des carcasse pour
faire des plats et qui si bien sûr si si
ils sont habitués quand les cuisiniers à
tout ça ils savent comment ça fonctionne
donc
j'aime pas trop maintenant c'est vrai
qu'ils disent on a préparé ça pendant
des jours et des jours préparer des
trucs on a travaillé sur le menu etc
parce que c'est pareil le menu on
demande à l'Élysée d'abord qu'est-ce qui
va te servir au dîner d'État parce que
généralement le premier jour de visite
officiel il y a un dîner d'État l'Elysée
et ensuite nous on appelle les femmes à
manger que vous avez fait boire et que
ça va faire boire et en fonction voilà
j'imagine que
c'est vrai qu'on est de plus en plus
exigeant aujourd'hui avec ce que l'on
mange on regarde d'où viennent les
étiquettes et puis il y a certaines
personnes qui ne mangent plus de viande
par exemple il y a des antispécistes il
y a des véganes on sait qu'il y a des
sans gluten puisque Manuel Valls c'était
sans gluten il y a comme ça des premiers
ministres qui ont eu des habitudes
alimentaires un peu différentes ou qu'on
ne connaît pas alors des premiers
donc c'est un peu compliqué au début
parce que c'était un peu le début
des produits sans gluten on trouvait pas
grand chose à cette époque là et quand
il fallait faire un dessert sans gluten
c'était c'était drôle référent donc ça
se termine on achète de fruits oui voilà
c'était la salade de fruits avec
classique
oui d'accord ah non non même si après je
décide de dire pour une autre il y a pas
envie de manger pour je ne sais quelle
raison les autres on leur sert le menu
classique la personne dit rien vous
savez quoi ils sont chez le Premier
ministre tout le monde qui est reparti à
la cuisine directement parce que c'était
un mangeable c'était trop cuit c'est
raté on va venir on imagine
non mais ratage
non il y a pas eu de rater il y a une
fois une entrée a été servie qui était
qui était pas terrible à mon humble avis
bon on a eu des retours qui étaient pas
terrible non plus après mais bon à sauté
dragon 1
à base de dentifices
qu'on ait jamais fait mais d'autres
endroits on a des bons chefs à Matignon
est-ce qu'il y a des premiers ministres
qui se transformaient une fois à table
parce que souvent on dit que la table
transformer l'homme il peut être
taciturne comme ça puis complètement
solaire à table parce qu'il est il est
rablaisien est-ce qu'il y avait des
personnalités qui avaient une
personnalité différente lorsqu'elles
étaient avec une fourchette et un
couteau entre les mains par rapport à
leur vie de tous les jours non parce que
vous savez quand ils sont à table c'est
hier soir par exemple je ne sais pas des
journalistes pour un déjeuner
les 7 huit journées se trouvent lui
poser des questions lui il va pas manger
Édouard Philippe ne mange absolument
rien il pouvait pas manger toutes les
secondes
donc non non ils n'ont bien souvent pas
le temps de manger donc la notion de
plaisir n'était jamais là sauf le
weekend quand ils sont tout seul avec
nous à la campagne dans la maison qui
est réservé au chef de gouvernement
voilà mais le résultat matin il mange
parce qu'il faut il faut manger il faut
venir le coup parce que les journées
sont longues et dures donc voilà ils a
pris pas forcément ils ont pas le temps
d'apprécier pas qu'on leur sert on dit
que c'est l'enfer Matignon est-ce que
vous pensez que pour ces premiers
ministres c'était l'enfer vous en avez
vu souffrir terriblement
l'enfer on peut pas dire ça j'ai vu
parfois des premiers ministres
pas bien si vous voulez alors on sait
pas ce qui se passe vous savez nous on
dit bonjour surprise avec un grand
sourire ils vont pour bonjour On dit
hola aujourd'hui il y a peut-être
quelque chose alors qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé avec autre chose l'actualité on
sait jamais ils sont pas toujours à fond
c'est super souriant tout ça ils ont ils
ont leur préoccupations aussi qui sont
qui sont importantes quand même ils font
un drôle de boulot quand même mais
franchement non j'ai pas j'ai pas
l'enfer matin
moi je serai pas rester si longtemps et
puis les premiers mois il s'y plaisent à
Matignon même si c'est dur il suffit de
voir les photos quand ils arrivent quand
ils s'en vont
un petit coup de vieux quand même mais
c'est vrai c'est vrai mais c'est pas
évident c'est une maison qui est dure
c'est ça n'arrête jamais matin non
il y avait un directeur de cabinet il
disait c'est un peu comme les garafaite
il se passe quelque chose toutes les
minutes quoi c'est le directeur de
cabinet de Michel Rocard et c'est vrai
il se passe tout le temps quelque chose
donc vous vous êtes toujours sur le kiné
[Musique]
sur place au cas où le premier Miss
France où il y a un truc qui se passe
quelque chose on a besoin de faire
quelque chose et vous vous avez été en
pleine nuit parfois
chambre
quand il les attentats j'étais chez moi
et je suis rentré parce que là je vais
me passer à nuit à Matignon j'ai passé
deux ou trois une fois qu'il y a un
incendie ce que j'étais là aussi ce
jour-là et quand il y a des choses
graves on revient mais on n'a pas besoin
de nous le demander on revient comme ça
etc il faut aider et là il y a besoin de
les dire le coup en leur donnant manger
à boire du café des trucs je ne sais
quoi enfin voilà il y a toujours quelque
chose alors je le disais vous êtes un
jeune retraité de Matignon mais vous
poursuivez quand même votre métier de
formateur pour insérer des personnes en
situation de handicap à l'école Médéric
le handicap en cuisine on en parle et on
met les pieds dans le plat
rien ne distingue rien de l'extérieur ne
distingue les restaurants le reflet
Brigitte de leur concurrents et pourtant
ici en cuisine et en salle se joue une
expérience humaine inédite avec du
personnel atteint de trisomie 21 c'est
le premier restaurant inclusif de France
bien sûr tout est fait adapté penser
pour faciliter les tâches des cuistots
et des serveurs et leur rencontre avec
la clientèle c'est un reportage
incroyable à Nantes de Hélène Bonduelle
et d'Antoine Coutin
après un café a été après un café après
le dessert
aussi à l'aise avec les clients qu'avec
ces collègues Maxime porteur d'une
trisomie 21 travaille depuis 5 ans comme
serveur dans ce restaurant
pour faciliter le quotidien de Maxime et
ses collègues ce tableau où chaque tâche
à effectuer et traduite par des
pictogrammes oraliser les choses c'est
bien mais c'est pas suffisant il faut
toujours en appui visuel ça permet aux
équipes de savoir où ils vont et aussi
de les amener à être beaucoup plus
autonome dans les tâches à accomplir dès
le matin et ils savent comment ce qu'ils
ont à faire dans la matinée le
restaurant a été entièrement pensé pour
les salariés en situation de handicap le
projet est né dans la tête de Flore il
elle est alors étudiante en architecture
d'intérieur et prépare son diplôme de
fin d'études mon sujet c'était comment
peut-on créer grâce à l'archive
intérieur et design d'objets un lieu et
des outils de travail qui s'adapte à des
personnes qui ont une crise 2021 pour
qu'elle puisse travailler comme tout le
monde un lieu qui sera à la fois
créateur d'emploi en milieu ordinaire
parce qu'aujourd'hui quand on a une
crise 2021 c'est super compliqué de
trouver un job
dans une entreprise classique avec un
salaire classique et également créer la
rencontre entre ces personnes qu'on voit
trop peu et le reste de la société et ça
commence par la mise à contribution des
clients
[Musique]
un tampon devant chaque plat choisi et
numéroté pour faciliter la prise de
commande
[Musique]
ça se passe et voilà
deux cuillères de cuillère pas plus
on cuisine aussi la vaisselle a été
ajustée comme ses assiettes avec une
meilleure prise en main et Virginie la
chef qui encadre les cuisiniers a appris
à s'adapter à prendre le temps à écouter
à être
à l'écoute de chacun des ressentis à
être plus aussi sur la sensibilité
être attentif aux autres
[Musique]
de pasta à la 6 Pauline
restauration on est dans amener des
personnes à s'épanouir au travail par le
travail à s'auton va être autonome ça
veut dire que derrière aussi ils ont ils
ont une paye ils sont salariés ils sont
CDI génial parce qu'on parle de
l'inclusion des
personnes en ligne
un deuxième restaurant Le Reflet à
d'ailleurs ouvert à Paris il y a 2 ans
et demi
alors que le Buzet ce reportage est
étonnant alors s'agit-il de restaurant
qui resteront à jamais expérimentaux ou
pensez-vous que ces établissements
inclusifs avec ces personnes atteintes
de trisomie 21 peuvent se développer de
façon un peu plus générale alors d'abord
Flora fait qu'elle a responsable de ces
deux restaurants à Paris il y a un an de
reflets elle a fait un travail
formidable avec du personnel trisomique
donc c'est un peu plus compliqué pour
pour travailler donc d'où les
équipements particuliers de restaurant
moi j'ai la chance de aujourd'hui que
d'être aussi f.a Médéric à Paris d'ici
hôtelier classique et dedans moi j'ai
quelques élèves qui sont handicapés que
je forme mais le but c'est quand même
les emmener dans le milieu ordinaire et
en ça est-ce que ça peut généraliser
c'était ça la question est-ce que ça va
être ces partout parce que là on a que
deux restaurants en France c'est rien
enfin il y en a deux deux comme ça le
type le reflet à Paris vous avez la
belle étincelle vouloir pasteur joyeux
il y a de plus en plus en France
également aussi beaucoup il y en a pas
mal quand même mais le but quand même
moi je pense c'est très bien mais je
pense que c'est difficile très dans le
milieu ordinaire et vraiment c'est
compliqué donc
équipements handicap ne pourront pas
trouver une place dans des institutions
classiques il faut il faut essayer si le
maximum il faut essayer de déplacer le
maximum dont une fois de plus il y a le
chef aléno nous prend beaucoup
d'apprentis on l'a reçu qui viennent
beaucoup de de Médéric en particulier de
jeunes handicapés qu'on est handicap
divers mais pas forcément on a un petit
un jeune qui est triste mais quand même
chez lui qui s'appelle Michael qui a un
garçon absolument génial que je suis
depuis longtemps vous poussez d'autres
chefs à le faire à suivre l'exemple de
Yannick
à embaucher des jeunes il y a des
réticences au départ vous les sentez un
peu méfiants alors ils se disent tous
Voilà il faut quelqu'un qui l'accompagne
en permanence pas faux il faut vraiment
quelqu'un il faut un tuteur vraiment
pour pour accompagner mais on y arrive
ça existe on a formé beaucoup d'élèves
déjà ça fait 5 ans que je fais ça
Médéric on a des beaux résultats c'est
obligé à doubler quasiment le personnel
à ce moment-là
autour d'eux ça le fait on n'a pas
besoin de prendre des gens en plus mais
grâce à ce que font Médéric c'est de
mélanger des élèves classiques enfin
entre guillemets classique et les autres
qui sont en situation handicap ils
apprennent à travailler ensemble pas le
reflet à cause des encadrants c'est 80%
des charges ça représente 80% du chiffre
d'affaires les la masse salariale
beaucoup plus qu'un restaurant
conventionnel ce que c'est quand même
pas un frein au développement ou est-ce
qu'il faudrait que l'État les pouvoirs
publics les aides parce qu'ils sont pas
vraiment aidés ces restaurants qui qui
emploient beaucoup de je sais pas
vraiment de m'entendre je sais que
l'État est beaucoup quand même les aides
légales mais il y a pas d'aide
exceptionnelles parce que on emploie des
des trisomiques 21 je pourrai pas vous
dire en tous les cas c'est le cas du
reflet c'est ce que Hélène Bonduelle m'a
dit
comment vous y prenez vous pour former
ces jeunes est-ce qu'il faut une
attention particulière ah c'est pas
simple c'est pas simple parce que bon
quand on les a les premiers jours pour
eux ils ont jamais travaillé de leur vie
je veux dire jamais fait un métier et
ben par contre ils sont très heureux
d'être à l'école croyez-moi il ne manque
jamais ils sont là tous les jours ils
sont là en avant et ils adorent faire ce
qu'ils font et vous les voyez progresser
quand même l'année passée on envoyait
une jeune fille qui s'appelle Flavie qui
est parti au Cap en deuxième année là ça
peut être quoi ça paye de service et on
a cette année deux élèves sur les cinq
que j'ai qui ont mis en CAP également
donc il va avoir un saper comme tout à
chacun sinon on a un titre pro qui ne
reconnaissance également pour former les
gens mais on arrive à les diplômés à les
faire embaucher et comment vous y prenez
parce que là on voyait dans le reportage
il y a des pictogrammes pour aider il y
a des numéros de table qui permettent
un milieu ordinaire donc ils apprennent
comme les autres ils apprennent à
remplir des bons de commandes c'est
difficile pour eux c'est difficile
je suis toujours
met du temps mais beaucoup de temps ça
dure j'ai cours jusqu'à la fin mais à
peu près depuis 7 ans mais on y arrive
c'est plus facile visiblement en salle
qu'on cuisine en cuisine il y a trop de
contraintes la température en cuisine
c'est les couteaux c'est les cheveux
mais enfin en cuisine on achète pareil
qui qui m'accompagne à Médéric qui est
là tous les lundis mardi en tant que moi
et qui forme des jeunes cuisiniers mais
avec des résultats également et puis je
dois dire aussi une chose quand même
c'est que les ministères nous emploient
beaucoup de jeunes comme ça en moins
pour les stages déjà premier temps et
beaucoup de ministères jouent le jeu en
prenant des jeunes en situation par
exemple bien sûr
l'intendant avait toujours donné un
accord pour ça il a toujours été pour tu
me demandes d'une ancienne chef de
cabinet qui avait commencé à nous parler
de ça et depuis ça se perpétue et tant
mieux ça dure longtemps je pense encore
ils sont très opérationnels parce qu'on
sait que quand il y a le ce qu'on
appelle le coup de feu il faut vite
pouvoir servir pouvoir sentir les plats
il faut s'adapter est-ce qu'ils sont
capables de faire ça alors les gens sont
bienveillants les clients que ça soit
dans le ministère ou ailleurs évidemment
tout le monde fait attention
non non vraiment vraiment
le reste rouge j'exerce au lycée
hôtelier au CFA là il y a pas de souci
les clients parfois juridiques quand ils
voient qu'il y a un truc il va pas j'y
suis un petit jeune que ce soit pas
forcément c'est pas non non
mais ils sont bienveillants les clients
croyez-moi et du coup ça change le
regard que peuvent avoir les gens sur le
handicap
ils veulent être servir tout le temps
c'est Michael qui nous sert à tel qu'il
nous sert et je suis content vous voyez
non non ils sont bienveillants les
clients sont bienveillants alors on sait
que le métier traverse une crise de la
vocation il y a une pénurie de main
d'oeuvre des restaurateurs n'y arrivent
plus est-ce que cette main d'offre qu'on
a pendant des décennies négligés
finalement mis de côté là on commence à
comprendre qu'ils ont des aptitudes
qu'ils sont même qui sont capables de
s'intégrer dans un restaurant est-ce que
on peut compter sur eux pour pour
essayer de de
d'occulter cette pénurie de main
d'oeuvre ça serait bien moi j'espère
bien qu'on va faire ça qui vont petit à
petit prendre des postes des vrais
postes pérennes pour pour que ça voilà
pour ça ce sera vraiment ça serait un
vrai changement il y a encore du boulot
on va faire hein
suffisamment
la passerelle qu'on les dans d'autres
écoles maintenant on fait beaucoup
quand même par les ministères quand même
je propose de passer au dessert Claude
Buzet c'est le péché mignon
je crois que vous êtes servis voici venu
donc le temps du sucré avec une tarte
normande c'est très simple pour poser de
pommes bien sûr on est en Normandie
d'une garniture composée de farine 2 de
crème de sucre est un peu de calvados
parce que
la pâte brisée bien sûr la tarte peut
être avantagement avantageusement cerclé
d'un anneau en bois qui assure la tenue
lors de la cuisson c'est comme ça que
font les Normands monsieur Buzet et
c'est vrai que cette tarte normande
constitue un élément incontournable de
l'identité culturelle de la Normandie ou
la production on le sait de pommes est
importante et j'ai appris que chaque
pays normand chaque petit terroir
normand et bien se vante d'avoir la
meilleure tarte normande voilà alors
vous les mets comment la tarte normande
il y a pas que des pommes il y a un peu
de crème il y a du sucre il y a des œufs
absolument là ça me plaît bien oui c'est
très joli
et alors quelle pomme vous déjà vous
savez l'affaire cette tarte normande
[Rires]
partout donc mais surtout qu'elle est à
l'école on fabrique beaucoup de desserts
on a des pâtisseries et donc je goûte
régulièrement et alors là les pommes
vous vous aimez quoi comme pomme vous
les pommes plutôt acides plutôt sucrées
j'aime bien la Pink Lady comme pomme moi
j'ai comme ça et je mange dans une
petite pomme il y a un nom bizarre
j'arrive pas à le retenir petite pomme
rouge et un peu vert non c'est pas sur
la j'ai vu ça hier on en achetant c'est
petit c'est bon c'est sucré c'est
parfait
les desserts à base de pommes
alors oui mais pas que j'aime bien alors
je suis assez simple dans mes goûts
j'aime bien les crêpes aussi j'aime bien
les gaufres et ça c'est des cercles que
j'aime vraiment et ça vous savez les
faire peut-être
gaufres et Monsieur très content
moi je les crêpes alors vous mettez quoi
du sucre alors là on est plus enfant
c'est quand même meilleur avec du
romarier
non mais en temps normal c'est du sucre
et puis je disais un peu de chocolat ou
un peu de gourmander aussi c'est bon
c'est pas mal dans les grandes maisons
dans les institutions oui des crêpes
avec un peu de d'Orange
sont en période
de Chandeleur
tous les jours donc je connais par cœur
alors les desserts qui étaient le plus
souvent servi à Matignon vous diriez que
c'était que c'était quoi on a un très
bon pâtissier à Matignon qui s'appelle
Gaëlle qui là depuis presque 15 ans
maintenant qui est un très très bon
pâtissier
leur proche que j'ai mais c'est un truc
qui va pas vous étonner c'est qu'on a
tendance à revisiter les choses et moi
j'ai dit toujours avant visiter parce
que
il m'a dit c'est quoi ça mille-feuille
revisité il était tellement revisité que
ça ressemble à tout sauf un
mille-feuilles donc j'ai vu au pâtissier
écoute je me suis fait engueuler par le
patron
il a pas trouvé ton truc là mais je
partage un peu son avis c'est vrai que
parfois on a des tiramisu revisités
en général
le coût de la revisite là parfois c'est
bon pour tous les plats aussi hein
supportable mais c'est un truc de vieux
donc moi donc voilà on dit qu'il faut
pas trop manger dessus certains premiers
ministres font j'imagine attention à
leur ligne est-ce qu'on sert de moins en
moins de desserts est-ce qu'on servait
de moins en moins de desserts alors on
en sert toujours mais par exemple Jean
Castex j'en prenais pas
un yaourt quand il y avait parfois assez
quand
tu avais des collaborateurs
et sinon vous lui apportiez quand même
le planning comme ça
quand c'était pas trop revisité quand
même non non mais c'est non non on a des
bonnes pâtisseries
et on sait que la pâtisserie française
vous disiez que vous aviez un bon
pâtissier la pâtisserie française et
elle est reconnue dans le monde entier
j'imagine quand il y avait des chefs
d'État étrangers ou des personnalités
étrangères elles étaient très
impatientes de goûter ça non parce que
oui c'est vrai qu'on soignait
particulièrement plus les desserts que
dans les soigner parce que c'est avec un
truc un peu spectaculaire voilà moi je
me suis rendu au chocolat avec des
fruits dedans et reverser du chocolat
qui faisait front de la boule et ça
coule au fond du truc c'est très sympa
on les mettait
c'est un truc qui plait bien si vous
voulez autrement non mais j'ai une fois
de plus je vous dis pas de l'air pas de
de ficelle vous mangez comme ça vous
appréciez pas forcément sauf ceux qui
sont plutôt dans dans les boutables ils
parlent pas ils prennent des notes ou
ils mangent
tout le temps les pauvres mais on se
retrouve bien sûr la semaine prochaine
pour un nouveau numéro de politique à
table sur LCP